hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 12 2017 what's going on how
are ya um and I know what you're
thinking yeah you're probably saying
what do you mean it's time for the
Monday morning podcast bill it's so late
what the [ __ ] um it's late this week
what here you're never late do you go
ahead jeah show up in your wife's like
where were you
we were waiting well it's all cold now
you know you want to look at her the way
Vince McMahon looked at that guy in the
Sports Show go oh oh [ __ ] slap a
piece of paper out of her hand but you
can't because all your relatives are
there watching so then he got to sit
there and make excuses
ah the the street like down the street
was busted so it was just blinking red
or blinking you know yellow so it was
real slow and there was water coming out
of the sewers and some guy I could
believe it some guy in a hang-glider
square - can - God hand to God he geek
got blown off course and he landed all
right right on the side of his
supermarket yeah hit the side of it he
went down in the book why can't you just
admit you were late because you don't
care about me
it's not that I don't care much it's
just I just don't give a [ __ ] about this
and I thought maybe if I showed up a
little later then it'd be less minutes
I'd have to spend at this yes no okay
you know what I'm saying uh god forbid
any of my relatives listen to this I
like all my relatives I got lucky I came
from I came from a cool family and I
married into a cool family you know to
me so there you go now am i just
covering my bases nobody knows why can't
I get the [ __ ] internet here I don't
you know why cuz I spend nine million
I'm one I'm like this do you know I
still have cable I have a dish whatever
and I get all the packages and I know at
this point you have these cord cut
they just cut the cord and they they
saying [ __ ] network TV [ __ ] 60 minutes
[ __ ] all of that [ __ ] I guess it's all
just going to end up on the computer
just every TV show is going to have an
app or every network is going to have an
app and within the app will be all the
shows I'm sure that already exists
because I know this HBO hot take or
online or streaming now whatever the
[ __ ] it's called SummerSlam
Showtime SummerSlam whatever the [ __ ]
they're calling it
so I'm old-school the reason why I'm
old-school it's not because I'm
down-to-earth yeah it's because I do not
want to waste one second of my [ __ ]
life trying to figure out how the new
[ __ ] works
all right that's the reason I've always
bought cars and I Drive them for a
decade I just keep changing the [ __ ]
oil that's what I do the only reason why
I went from the Prius to the Jag is just
because my daughter was coming and I was
just like I better buy a cool car before
she gets here or I'm gonna be [ __ ] and
I never bought myself a cool car because
I don't know I've always been a frugal
son of a [ __ ] you know I didn't want
that stupid [ __ ] you know when I was you
drive down the street with your whole
[ __ ] cool ass car and everybody
turned around looking at you I like
blending in the background you know
leave me alone dive bar dive bar guard
not not VIP not down there at the
[ __ ] sushi restaurant we're all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] hanging out with the
cameras you know whatever that [ __ ]
show is so anyways you know I had like a
really bad cab driver back from LAX I
take cabs cuz I'm not downloading that
[ __ ] app onto my phone and then you
track me and see where the [ __ ] I am
those uber [ __ ] all right [ __ ] them
so yeah I just take the taxi so I get in
the cab and we're driving he goes how do
you want to go I go let's take the
[ __ ] highways right it's the middle
of the day here
so you know I always peek out the
windows we come into LAN to see what the
old floral fizzy looks like and so
whatever we get on the goddamn thing and
I notice the guy's not in the HOV Lane
I'm like buddy there's two of us here we
are the world was saving we're thinking
locally and acting globally right this
is Greenpeace here we have two people in
a car we get to use the diamond lane and
he's like oh my god go out there [ __ ]
he didn't have the EZ Pass thing
whatever it is and I'm like how come we
don't have that he goes all cost money
in his accent it costs money yeah but
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it your job is driving
people around you [ __ ] if you had
that thing you could get people to and
from where they're going and you could
you could pick up more people right you
could make more money so I'm in the back
you know big Hollywood phony getting all
grumpy troll look at look at look at
Bill oh look at him he's getting a taxi
cab he didn't forget where he came from
two seconds later I'm [ __ ] bitching
out this [ __ ] poor old bastard in my
own passive-aggressive way just mumble
in the backseat I don't [ __ ] do you not
have the [ __ ] thing that's what the
[ __ ] I mean this is on me should I you
should have said that as you pulled up
or whatever right so then he just had no
instincts you know we go to get off our
exit
you know onto another [ __ ] highway so
there's the long line that all the
[ __ ]
wade in and then there's the Raley ray
liotta line right [ __ ] you pay me going
in through the cook kitchen people work
9:00 to 5:00 that was for schnooks
right we didn't ask me anything we
wanted we just we just took it and then
when it was all said and done you bust a
joint out right you take that [ __ ]
you go around everybody like you're
still going straight in the last seconds
you put on your right hand directional
you get in somebody beeps at you who
gives a [ __ ] and there you are
all right those are basic skills that a
cab driver should have and he gets in to
the [ __ ] soccer-mom line and I'm just
like this guy is the worst and
I was just like you know what he's an
old man he drives a cab bill okay who
gives a [ __ ] so then I just said you
know what who gives a [ __ ] then he goes
which way do you want me to go which
highway I go does it even matter at this
point it's like you're gonna sit in the
longest I didn't say this part you gonna
sit in the longest line you don't have
the [ __ ] HOV thing I mean you want to
just pull over get some lunch I mean
know what [ __ ] we're going here so
anyways we get up to that my house
he goes I pay and I say credit card so
he takes my credit card and he does the
whole thing reach it through the little
[ __ ] divider window there and then he
hits no tip and I go - why'd you had no
tip he goes he goes no I don't know the
thing he goes I deserve to be punished
that's what he said and I said Jesus
quite not taking it to that level
I was upset a half an hour I'm gonna
[ __ ] tip you he goes no I don't
deserve above a blonde I got though
don't fine I'm just made me sad don't
ever say that so I never gave him 20
bucks cash and he's all [ __ ] me like
I'll get you changed you win is this how
you do it maybe that's his scam he
doesn't have the thing and then in the
end he [ __ ] just puts his head down
and goes I don't deserve a tip and then
a [ __ ] soft he goes no yes you do
and then he gets $20 tip even though
he's stuck at what he was doing and he
still doesn't have to pay for the thing
I think you know what I think I got I
think I got scammed I think I fell for I
think I bought a you know a VCR and I
open it up and it's just a brick in the
box remember that one that was the old
scam back in the 80s hey kid you want a
VCR 50 bucks you [ __ ] Hannity and
you've run away with the box you open it
up there was a brick in it
brilliant brilliant [ __ ] scam you
know cuz even if they ask to open up the
box you know what's in there so all you
got to do is that they go to open it you
just grab the brick before they do and
you smash him over the head then you
take everything in his wallet
sort of failsafe you know unless the guy
is bigger than you
then as he goes to open he just go cops
cops cops and you grab the box and you
get the [ __ ] out of it
I don't know I'm talking about so
anyways I had a great weekend I went up
to the I went up to Montreal Morel with
Sir Paul virzi on and Ruth M Ellis and
we did the Olympic theater on my
birthday Saturday night and he probably
wanted hate bill why did why would you
do stand-up on your birthday it's cuz I
wanted to go to the Formula One Formula
One race on June 11th and when I booked
it I wasn't thinking June 10th is my
birthday I just saw June 11th and that's
not an important day to me you know so
dumb I am it didn't dawn on me that my
birthday was the [ __ ] day before so
anyways I go up there and I go out when
Andrew brought me up he goes uh keep it
going for the birthday boy and he
brought me out and the crowd sang me
happy birthday was awesome
had a fun show I get off stage and I
walked down to the green room and some
people from Just for Laughs were there
and they got me this unbelievable cured
meat from someplace with bread and they
had all like the what's that kids movie
um you know with the cars talk what is
that is it called cars I don't know I
don't you know I just I'm new to the kid
game whatever so they had those all up
there like I was a five year old and
then my lady had sent me up a bottle of
Johnnie Walker Blue
which is funny because I was trying to
be Billie no fun and I was telling her
how great I felt not drinking and
getting eight hours sleep I'm talking on
my birthday and she goes I ought to have
a couple tonight you have a couple
tonight and I was like Nia why do you
always do this to me
I'm trying to do the right thing we're
trying to go to bed early and you always
like bill you're not an alcoholic stop
being so dramatic you know and then I
realized oh it's cuz she got me the
Johnnie Walker blue so I called her up
and then she you know we had a good
laugh about that so I had a little shot
of that before I did the second show and
then the second show at the end of that
virzi anthem Alice brought out a cake
with candles on it and [ __ ] and everyone
was singing happy birthday again
it's a 1400 seater I had 2800 people
most people didn't like my act towards
the end sing me happy birthday was one
of the best birthdays I've ever had
so I'm an [ __ ] I go to blow out the
candles and like I got to make a wish I
got to make a wish I'm in Montreal I go
I wish for a Bruins Stanley Cup
championship next year they're all like
bad it was funny though it was their
reaction made me laugh and I blew up
part of the candles without the rest of
them so I guess we're not winning next
year but I really want to thank
everybody that came out I had such a
[ __ ] great time both shows and that
really is one of the great cities that
I've ever been to I love that place I
wish I had more time to spend there but
um you know I kind of flew up and I was
just tired from that whole week of
running around you've run in my yeah
promoting the show so I just sort of
went into the fetal position before the
show I didn't get to walk around and see
anything then I did the two shows and
then I went right back to bed went right
to bed and got eight hours sleep and
then woke up and went to my first
Formula One race which I have to tell
you lived up to the hype I don't even
know where to begin as far as like going
out to just see seeing this event that I
don't even know what like a year and a
half ago I sort of knew the sport
existed I mean I knew about it but I
wasn't you know doing all this [ __ ] yeah
B you know watching every single
so now to finally show up you know what
that going on was like I don't know how
to explain it like the Karstens just
seeing the cars alone was like seeing a
celebrity to me
like oh that's a Ferrari that's that's
the [ __ ] that's the Mercedes team ah
there's the fuchsia the Force India team
you know it was incredible experience we
get there we you know we park then you
take a little boat over and I know it
was crazy you know the guy who does all
the wrap-up [ __ ] you know the interviews
and everything before and after will
Buxton he came out to the show he was
telling us you got to come down to the
pit area whatever the [ __ ] they call it
the I forget what the [ __ ] they called
but we had these sick ass passes and we
had just under a loominatee level seats
you know every time you think you're in
the best place you could watch it you
find out there's another more
air-conditioned area with even older
manicured looking dudes with younger
hotter looking chicks every time you
think you're at the Fiat the final level
of Dante's Inferno there's another
[ __ ] level it's incredible you know
there was a whole there was one other
level above where the hell we were at
and that's where the guys look like you
know what Celine Dion's husband used to
look like you know that guy and he was a
ball dude he basically looked like Rob
Reiner but he was the [ __ ] shape
shift shifter like lizard level you know
one of those guys that always dresses
all in white like he's a bald dude but
even like just the [ __ ] he had left on
the side you like that's like a [ __ ]
thousand dollar haircut his beard was
like perfectly manicured you know what I
mean those guys those guys who's like
their whole wardrobe is like linen and
they think yeah they walk around like in
Christ's clothes
they're always on the French Riviera now
he's in a [ __ ] yacht they got private
jets and then there's always some
meerkat looking chick sitting next to
him that's like [ __ ] like you know 21
22 and you're like oh my god did you
pull up in your [ __ ] World Cup's
sailboat you know go into a town and
just walk up to these broke people just
you know genetic you know they hit the
lottery genetics and had this beautiful
girl and you just took her away
you know the open-toed [ __ ] sandals I
remember that guy Celine Dion's husband
I just remember he not only was he bald
but his head was perfectly tan so it
didn't even look bad and then he just
had this angelic white hair on the side
what same thing with like the his beard
it was a different kind of white you
know like that you know like those fancy
[ __ ] paint you can get with it's just
a hint of another color and then I don't
know what was in there but you can see
why soon Celine was just so in love that
she was punching herself in the [ __ ]
chest every night couldn't get way to
get back I mean if that's what is it
[ __ ] hair and then side of his head
and his beard look can you imagine this
guy's pubes I must be here like a pack
perfectly tan junk you know with his
[ __ ] angelic wing to pubes I can't
even imagine that bit yet we didn't get
to that level we got to the level where
was a bunch of people like just [ __ ]
real race fans we got to the level where
we had a canopy and I still got a
[ __ ] sunburn that's how white I am
you know cuz the Sun wasn't on my head
but it hit my [ __ ] chest so got all
[ __ ] read and but I want to thank
everybody at the f1 race everyone was so
[ __ ] cool so long story short I got
to make it funny man I had such a good
time so where's
like if you watch a replay of the race
when right when the they come out of the
pit you know to rejoin the race right
where they hit the acceleration you know
they got to drive like [ __ ] two and a
half miles an hour and then they get to
this point where they can [ __ ] take
off right right where they take off was
where we were sitting and we could see
turn one and then turn two and it's a
whole other game trying to watch the
race um when you're there if you don't
have like I mean I wish I brought like a
radio so I could have figured out what
the [ __ ] was going on because I didn't
know what happened to Vettel I didn't
know that the Red Bull guy you know it
was it
max max Maximilian there max Verstappen
right he clipped the front of his car I
had no idea what was going on all I know
is he pitted really early and I was like
what the [ __ ] and all of a sudden went
from second place to like 15th or last
in the race so I kind of knew but I had
no I had no idea what happened I didn't
know that that [ __ ] what's-his-face
there Kimi räikkönen I didn't know that
he had problems with his brakes
we had no [ __ ] idea no idea and it
was so [ __ ] loud yet earplugs in and
the guys talking over but it's just so
goddamn loud I'm jumping all over the
story here dude we took a little boat
over we parked in a garage and then you
get in this little boat takes you over
there and then we'll hook this up down
in the whole [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
they call it because of the P and we got
to look at the garages and all that [ __ ]
in and we went into the Red Bull one in
me virzi and family's got to meet Daniel
Ricciardo who I famously called Ricky
Ricky Rican in or some [ __ ]
Daniel Ricciardo nicest [ __ ] guy ever
and by the way I want to be in the shape
of an f1 driver
this guy's a [ __ ] ridiculous this guy
was like I don't know he's like 511 so
he's got me by a ninja so he was
probably thirty pounds lighter than me
[ __ ] amazing he goes yeah we get
weighed twice a day right before the
Reno during the race week or whatever it
was joking about some [ __ ] broccoli
thing that drink he just drank and how
much weight they lose when they're in
the car and all that type of stuff I
really want to thank Red Bull Racing how
how cool and nice they were and
everything they were kind of the exact
opposite of this [ __ ] [ __ ] we met
from the Ferrari team granted it was
after the race and I thought he was one
of the guys was cool he was really
really nice but the first guy we met was
a [ __ ] but I think he thought we will be
in [ __ ] because I didn't understand
I knew that Ferrari was having a
nightmare of a day but I didn't realize
the level I mean I thought it was so
cool that you know Vettel was able to
work his way back up to the field I was
kind of paying attention to him I wasn't
paying attention to Kimi so when I went
down there I know I didn't know what to
say the guy was like after the race all
those Ferrari guys are like smoking
cigarettes too it's [ __ ] hilarious
all tanned up [ __ ] smoking cigarettes
and I just walked up and I was just like
I was just like hey man is it okay good
first he gets a picture with you because
he wanted a picture with somebody from
Ferrari
you know he's half Sicilian you know so
the guys just li he's like yeah yeah and
I said hey you know you know good race
today you know you guys at least you got
by the forced India guys and his face
just dropped and I swear to God in his
face
I understood the entire history and the
pressure of working on Ferrari like he
just looked us I can't even he didn't
say anything and then he just went uh I
said ah and I was trying to make it nice
again I was I thought made a good race
when they had a horrific race he
probably thought they didn't know this
was my first event so he probably
thought I was [ __ ] with him say
probably not a [ __ ] but if you could
have seen this guy's face [ __ ] drop I
tell you if an actor ever did what this
guy's faced it in a movie you'd win an
Oscar and now Versys got to stand next
to him and firs II can read people
better than me
you know he's half Sicilian half Greek
it's [ __ ] over right so he feels
uncomfortable so I'm trying to make it
nice going like alright this is going to
be a legendary picture whatever
then he goes on no and he takes the
picture and then the [ __ ] the guy who
I thought it was a [ __ ] but probably
thought we were a [ __ ] he goes now you
just missed the legend go by Mike oh he
goes out Vettel that'll just walk by
we're like really where'd he go he goes
I went right in there and we believed
him and then Andrew figured out later
that he was just [ __ ] with us and
then we met somebody else in the friar
team which was really nice but anyways
it was a it was just an amazing [ __ ]
time I don't even know I don't know I I
don't know how to do it justice it's too
was too much to try to put all into I
guess I started at the [ __ ] middle
and then went back to the beginning and
then I went to the end of the [ __ ]
race just know in the end we were
sitting outside of Lewis Hamilton's
garage you know after everybody left and
there was all these fans there and they
introduced the whole team the crowd goes
crazy like Racing's really big with the
fence like they do all this extra stuff
they're great so then they were chant
Lewis's name and Lewis comes out again
with another bottle of champagne he
sprays it on his team and then sort of
whipped around in our direction and we
actually got hit with the champagne from
Lewis Hamilton that's how [ __ ] close
we were so I don't know how to ever top
that experience but like I'd like to say
again thank you to everybody who you
know Bruce Hills and all those guys from
just for laughs for hooking us up we had
a great time and yeah I don't know what
to tell you but I kind of realized just
going through talking everybody in like
the garages and [ __ ] just how it's like
Mercedes won't give redbull they try to
buy an engine I guess from Mercedes and
they're like yeah now we're not giving
you that basically because Daniel
Ricciardo is too good of a [ __ ]
driver we don't need that competition
however they will sell it to other
[ __ ] teams like I think for Scindia
they gave them but it's not the same
Mercedes engine that they have it's
really [ __ ] weird like it's like art
will sell an engine to a team that we
know we could beat so we can make the
money and help pay for the [ __ ] team
but we're not going to give it to a good
team but I don't get how like redbull
when when what's-his-face uh Vettel was
driving for one like [ __ ] three in a
row four in a row
and nobody could catch him it's like
what what what the [ __ ] happened a Red
Bulls engine over the last four years
you know I don't I got my [ __ ]
program here and I hope I'm not boring
you guys to [ __ ] I'm gonna get off this
quickly because I know that for me to
start talking about driving for [ __ ]
20 goddamn well at that taxing one was
that taxi was a nice mainstream story
wasn't it doesn't that count for
anything you [ __ ] [ __ ] know if I
look up the Mercedes team they've only
been around since uh 2010 now I know
Mercedes has been racing cars since the
1950s like I don't get how the Ferrari
teams been around since 1950
is this like some AMG [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to look up the history these teams
because I found it fascinating because
after a while I was like you know what
I'm not gonna root for Mercedes and
[ __ ] I'm not going to join this sport
and then root for the [ __ ] Yankees or
Red Sox and that's too easy right so I
kind of like I like Red Bull and I like
[ __ ] force India just cuz I had a
great time when I did that gig in Mumbai
and comedians over there were [ __ ]
hilarious breaking balls and stuff but
but then I saw the owner of the team or
whatever the director is is just some
[ __ ] white dude force india is there
like a [ __ ] disease looking dude
anywhere in there that's [ __ ] you
know you figure with the name like that
there's got to be an Indian dude you
know I don't [ __ ] know anyways what
am I talking about it um so I had a
great [ __ ] time how about that I'll
leave it at that
I'll leave it at that and
what's-his-face Lewis Hamilton got 25
[ __ ] points and uh now he's only what
like 12 behind he was twenty five behind
that was the one exciting thing was
watching Vettel work his way through the
field oh when I forgot to say all the
[ __ ] the Force India guys
even if you're not into this sport ah
they were going back and forth with one
another right the young kid was trying
to get through and the Perez guy
wouldn't let him through would not let
him through right what's the other guy's
name Oh cond wanted to get through he
wouldn't get him through so while they
were fighting with each other right at
fourth and fifth place Vettel you know
divided Connor conquered went by both of
them in the last couple of [ __ ] laps
and ended up getting into fourth place
which was [ __ ] huge you know and in a
way [ __ ] over the Mercedes team you
know and I bet they called them up and
say hey next time you [ __ ] fuchsia
[ __ ] want one of our [ __ ] engines
alright we give you one of our goddamn
engines and this is how you treat us you
plot the goddamn Ferraris okay a faster
car out front the [ __ ] are we doing here
I'll give you a [ __ ] Volkswagen
engine ooh you do that [ __ ] to me again
right I think that must have happened
somewhere along the line that that had
to have happened so is the Haase team
the American team it's so [ __ ]
confusing I'm sitting here looking at
McLaren Honda McLaren to me [ __ ]
worked on Mercedes and Honda used to
dominate the sport now this poor bastard
every time he goes around the [ __ ]
lap dude it's like he's driving a hoopty
the thing just shits the [ __ ] bed
every time he took a [ __ ] race off
wanted one of those guys Fernando Alonso
I think he said you know [ __ ] this I'm
gonna go I'm gonna take a race off
that's how bad your engines are and I'm
gonna go drive the Indy 500 and I
believe when he went there is his engine
quit - I'm not sure I've been flying all
over - hell all over the hell all over
hell so we went to the race I got
sunburned
we saw oh this stuff do what we were
sitting we literally saw them pull their
cars in in the end where was both
Mercedes Hamilton and botas and then
Daniel Ricciardo we saw him all shake
hands they walked up the stairs and then
we saw him you know on the podium we
would like to the side you know by the
way that [ __ ] trophy that you get
but when in that race Jesus Christ and
that decked is one of the worst [ __ ]
trophies I've ever seen in my life
I think it's just the Toronto that the
Toronto the Canadian Maple Leaf they
just sort of have it elevated with all
this stuff but it's just such a bland
they should make it like gold or
something with with the red outline of
Canada you know what I mean
red and white for Canada and then you
put a bunch of gold and there you shine
it up a little bit
Jesus Christ candidate all your
imagination going to the Stanley Cup I
don't know I was really disappointed
with the you know it's funny was the one
that Lewis Hamilton got was bad enough
the one that Daniel Ricciardo get I
swear to god he's probably using to prop
open some door in his house that's how
bad I gotta look this thing up I really
have to I got to trash this [ __ ]
thing a [ __ ] is it come on bill could
you believe that cab driver I deserve to
be punished I mean that's the kind of
mindset that's how you end up driving a
[ __ ] cab it's seventy years of age
and he's probably an immigrant people
the [ __ ] racist and they probably
never got an opportunity I mean that's
another thing Bill that's that's that
always can happen too you know all right
fair enough
hey fair enough you know who knows all
right
Montreal can't connect in a double dude
Canada Grand Prix you know was enjoying
me talking about this right now is
Nashville predator fans because the last
thing oh maybe it looks a little bit
better it's got some [ __ ] it's got a
little gold in there yeah it's just
sitting on like rebar it's just just no
imagination
I mean could you at least put like a red
outline around the gold could you do
something to [ __ ] dress this up I
swear to God if there's some [ __ ] up
reason I ever won that race I don't know
I got so into this game this this
[ __ ] sport and I somehow lost 90
pounds so I could actually not be a you
know causing the car to lose and I
somehow beat lewisham
- and fettle in a non Mercedes non
Ferrari engine car if they brought that
trophy out to me you know and I just
lost [ __ ] five pounds pissing myself
as I'm driving around the goddamn track
I would I just would be like yeah you
keep that thing you keep why don't you
go back and finish making that trophy
and then I'll accept it I'm sure that
wouldn't cause any any international
incident
speaking of an international incident
what the [ __ ] the Nashville Predators of
the dreaded I lost sight of the puck and
blew the whistle
welcome Nashville predator fans welcome
you guys are now officially been
baptized as hockey fans okay up until
now you were expansion expansion hockey
fans I didn't respect you even with your
chance
even with Nashville even though how far
you've come
I could not fully accept you as fans of
the National Hockey League until I saw
your team at a Stanley Cup final score a
goal but the ref lost sight of the puck
and it's waved off now you've earned
your stripes now you have a ref that you
hate you know now you got someone people
are going to send letters to and [ __ ]
make death threats and all the other
people take it too [ __ ] seriously can
you imagine that poor [ __ ] referee
listen the Nashville Predators fans
somehow figuring out his phone phone
number yeah but let me tell you what you
[ __ ] French [ __ ] five a case
you can't see again I swear to God I
swear God
I swear to God buddy I got some farming
equipment I'll figure out how to unrest
it just to run you over with that after
I shoot you in the [ __ ] face I can't
imagine the threats that he's getting
like I shouldn't even talk about it
that's probably not even funny
unbelievable un-fuckin'-believable but I
told you guys I [ __ ] told you I picked
the Penguins like I think I have
somewhere around the first rounds like I
know these guys look I don't see anybody
stopping I didn't see anybody that's why
I know after Webb once the Black Hawks
got knocked out I was just like yeah
[ __ ] that it's over they're gonna win
and then I lost faith with him you know
their goal tending towards the end of
the Ottawa series they proved me wrong
and then there was that game there was
that game game for that the Predators
one but that [ __ ] look on Crosby's
face when he scored that goal and he
didn't put his hands up like I scored a
goal he put him out to the side
you know gathering his [ __ ] teammates
in like that's one like total [ __ ]
business look on his face and
congratulations to the Penguins you
[ __ ] non-flying dirty Birds you did
it again
that's Crosby's third that's Malkin's
third they now have one more than the
[ __ ] great duo of Mario Lemieux and
Jaromir Jagr so that's that's really
saying something they got five they got
[ __ ] five you know I don't want to
start anything but they almost have
twice as many as the [ __ ] Flyers
twice as many as two flies Philadelphia
you're gonna sit there you gonna take
that [ __ ] you're gonna have to during
the off-season same way same way I do as
a Bruin fin I believe we have six
Stanley Cups but we've been around since
like Charles Lindbergh so that's
different
although the Penguins have been around
for 50 years already just like that who
would have thought um anyways let's talk
about old Billy no fun no fun Billy
what's the deal no fun Billy
um so after telling you I was gonna have
no fun uh you know it was my birthday I
was in Montreal but even then I didn't
go [ __ ] nuts like the last night we
went to my favorite cigar bar up in
Montreal we went to stogies and buy a
couple of [ __ ] gray goose even though
I like Belvedere gray goose is the Pepsi
of
vodka you don't I mean always like Coke
cause code had the bite you know give
you a [ __ ] right different you know
I'll speaking of that what about cold
lotion cold lotion of the week would
have to be they the Nashville Predators
scored a legal goal and the guy lost the
[ __ ] side of the puck that is that is
that is NHL referee cold lotion right
there that's what exactly what the [ __ ]
that was but yeah so I'm not a big Grey
Goose fan you know I feel like I know
much like that cab driver that feels
like he should be punished I feel like
when I'm drinking that I should be
feeling the effects of what I'm doing to
my body
I don't want it watered down you got to
drink the gas you know I like Belvedere
it's got a little more of a kick to it
although I'm not a big vodka guy so I
had that
I [ __ ] smoked a cigar after the race
10:30 old freckles was in bed okay so
when my alarm went off at 5:30 in the
morning from my early flight to get back
to my lovely wife and daughter I was
fine I was packed I was ready to [ __ ]
and go everything was fine and but now
it's official now back and it's just
like my big thing this year as a 49 year
old is eight hours sleep I got to do it
I got to do it because as much as I like
going out and partying and doing all
that [ __ ] nothing at my age feels better
than [ __ ] eight hours sleep so I'm
hoping that I can latch on to this
lifestyle and have that be my new
[ __ ] drug eight hours sleep yeah I
got to do it I don't know how to drink
recreationally I gotta be honest with
you I just don't you know I just if I'm
doing it I'm [ __ ] doing it's like I
got into f1 now look at me I'm spending
half the [ __ ] podcast probably
driving you guys up the goddamn wall
talking about this [ __ ] and now you know
I went to my first race I'm going to the
one in Austin and then immediately I
just go well that's that's two down two
down out of twenty if I do two a year
here's I can [ __ ] go to all of them
you know sometimes that works for me
sometimes it doesn't you know it works
for me as far as like trying to succeed
in life because I just get into
something and I [ __ ] do it and next
thing you know I cross the finish line
but you know when you apply that same
sort of philosophy to drinking it it
doesn't work it's all about after you
have the drink if you have the water
afterwards and you sort of sober
yourself back up again I don't know I
don't think I'm cut out for it so I need
to take anything I've been needing to
take time off for a good [ __ ] year so
that's what I'm doing right now I'm not
saying I'm not gonna drink for a [ __ ]
year but I'm definitely uh and I will
see be funny if I end up in a a you know
go to some [ __ ] meeting I'll never
admit that I'm an alcohol just gonna go
down and listen those [ __ ] stories
you know I mean the stories the stories
are funny but then afterwards he's
[ __ ] chain-smoking doughnut-eating
sad sacks you know I remember when I got
busted for drinking and driving one of
the one of the acquirements had to go to
two AAA meetings at a girl Mothers
Against Drunk Driving meeting and all
this community service I had to do and I
remember going to the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] a a meeting Jesus Christ just
went you know if you think you have an
alcohol problem go to an AAA meeting
good lord
these [ __ ] people holy [ __ ]
insane the [ __ ] stories waking up
with no teeth getting bailed out of jail
and [ __ ] walking out with no shoes
right across the street to a liquor
store I mean oh no maybe that's like an
extreme version I don't [ __ ] know
where's uh Lovelace let's read a little
bit of advertising here for this week
everybody huh-huh where the hell is it
where is it
no God somebody's gonna correct me on
kryptonite this week you guys just don't
[ __ ] let up do you unreal
last week what did I I guess the [ __ ]
superhero people they take it so goddamn
seriously
all right I have advertising if this
thing ever loads come on load it up I
never even finished talking about the
cable [ __ ]
I watched you know I pay so much [ __ ]
money for the internet and I pay so much
[ __ ] money for cable the [ __ ] doesn't
work you know that the f1 race didn't
even record it started to record and it
was just that shaking commercial that
you can't fast-forward past because I
wanted to see what what happened at the
beginning the race and then you know
what I went online and just found it so
maybe that's what I need to do to do to
do I have no idea oh and I didn't even
bring up the [ __ ] Cavaliers holy [ __ ]
what a game what a [ __ ] game
forty-eight first quarter points 86
points in the first half
un-fuckin'-believable and it was still
it took them halfway through the fourth
quarter that's how little competition
there is but you know something I think
when that little [ __ ] fella there the
guy who shoots the three-pointers is
probably a foot taller than me but he
looks like a little fellow in the NBA
court when he [ __ ] pretended to take
a [ __ ] there was one of the most
classless things I've ever seen he
pretends to take a [ __ ] and then runs up
to court wipes his ass and then wipes it
on the Cavalier logo and then afterwards
like yeah I was in the moment I don't
remember what I did get the [ __ ] out of
here get the [ __ ] out of here you don't
remember what you do you know exactly
what you did you [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] on the floor I don't know why
you know I gotta hit pause I got hit
pause to forget to open this [ __ ]
thing alright I'm back I'm back just
went out the kitchen I just saw my
dinner salmon salad with salmon oh good
[ __ ] salmon you know it's a tragedy
about salmon as how many salmon get
killed the year and people don't even
appreciate it you know it's like tuna -
the personality it's just like a [ __ ]
joking with Keith Robinson about that we
went out to dinners then you know the
fish option one it was just salmon and
he's just like Jesus Christ
it's like yeah salmon is salmon is a
[ __ ] middle act you know it's a
[ __ ] terminal feature of the fishing
world all right Luke Craig everybody be
the envy of your friends and get your
100% exclusive rate exclusive crates at
Luke rate calm / / and enter my code
burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription June's Luke rate theme is
alter-ego Luke rate offers an epic range
of pop-culture items for less than $20 a
month if you're more of a fanatic
fanatical fashionista then trilewd wear
monthly wearables and accessories with
Koch classics and your favorite
franchises if you want to get fancy get
a bigger box with even bigger loot I
have no idea what I'm talking about
right now with Luke Craig DX offer
expires June 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific I'm
just going to try it sound like I'm
excited about this stuff in Jude's Luke
rate you'll find items from spider-man
transformers The Hulk and DC comics one
lucky subscriber will also win a mega
crate of seriously epic proportions you
have until the 19th at 9 p.m. in case
you forgot the [ __ ] two sentences ago
Pacific time to subscribe and receive
that month's crate and then the cutoff
happens that's it it's over you now as
an adult cannot walk around dressed like
spider-man is that a good thing or a bad
thing I don't know I don't know maybe a
dress like spider-man and you find some
other nerd dress like Wonder Woman and
the two of you bang okay but how do you
get your dick out of that thing you got
to take the [ __ ] mask off first right
- spider-man and pull it all the way
down shimmy it over your [ __ ] fat
body
go to Luke Raycom slash burn into my
code birth to say $3 off on any new
subscriptions today oh but oh dude do
biondi's me undies look at that fat
spider man do to me undies me undies
Ichigo puke in the can
I'm not recommend
then being anorexic or whatever that
other one is where you eat and then you
puke but if your balls are soft you got
on me undies just don't puke down the
front of them because that will be
disgusting Celine Dion's angelic pubic
hair of her dead husband sorry that one
just went off the rails me undies
everybody elevates your underwear game
to the next level
Nia what sex what's that thing will you
you eat and then you puke not anorexia
bulimic Oh women a tough one biondi's me
undies donna ee me dudududu me undies me
undies [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah bulimia M&M
could ride that word bulimia something
Athenian irani a Aranea I can I can't do
it well it's a good thing I do remember
it alright me undies elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies you perfected your wardrobe but
what about the stuff not everybody gets
to see no we're not talking about your
junk we're talking about the cloth that
covers it if you've been settling for
store-bought underwear five packs I have
something that will change your life for
the better
me undies what's the first thing you put
on and the last thing you take off its
your underwear
unless you're Matthew McConaughey huh
him it's probably his boots right after
he steps out of a [ __ ] Lincoln
Continental threatens junk hanging out
um what I might make your your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies what is beyond
ease oh just seriously soft feel-good
undies delivered right to your [ __ ]
door me undies are designed in LA and
made from sustainably sourced micro
Modell modal a fabric three times softer
than cotton where did it go the copy
just went away the undies softer than
soft luxury undies come in an
ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shapes and adventurous
platforms so you can tailor your undies
to your own personal
style I always think with all the
different colors and all this stuff
that's what people like by like sex
swings you know what I mean
they just got to keep you know make it
exciting and guess what you can save
time and money each month with a monthly
subscription if you're not ready for the
subscription that's okay you can still
say that's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair just use our
special URL me undies dot-com / / b you
are r and get 20% off your first pair so
go ahead revamp your underwear drawer
you deserve it once again that's my
undies comm / / me undies comm / / -
more all right
wince wink winc whiskey India November
charlie when you have a great glass of
wine it enhances the moment uh you know
what you can't get drunk off a wine
Jesus Christ that's what they had at the
formula one they had Heinekens and then
they had white wine I drank I was like I
don't get all [ __ ] beer fat so I drank
like two white wines and you know I now
understand why so women uh so many women
a [ __ ] it's impossible to drink that
[ __ ] and get any sort of a nice buzz you
know it's just another thing that's
harder for women you know you have no
idea how difficult things are for us
somebody write an article okay
whether you're reflecting on the day or
with someone you love when you have a
great glass of wine it enhances the
moment wink understands this it's one
they started they're going to give you
access to exceptional wines from around
the world so you can have more of those
moments you know what I like a [ __ ]
Barolo
if you don't know [ __ ] about wine go to
wink and get a Barolo get one that's a
little fruity diff that's the one I like
I don't like those acidic ones um that's
a nice one and then there's one that's
sort of off the same vine it begins with
an N I can't remember Newbury Street in
Napoli I don't [ __ ] it up just go to try
try wink calm t ry winc calm take a
brief palate
I'll quiz and wink will recommend
distinct and interesting wines actually
customized to your palate to be shipped
directly to your door every month this
is a great way to learn about wine by
the way you know because it's a very
intimidating thing I found that Barolo
and I've stuck with that ever since then
I haven't dared [ __ ] with anything
French or anything I would do this if I
wasn't going to be boring Billy here
Billy no fun none of your time is wasted
fitting in to run to the store on your
way home from work on your way to
inventor gathering no more time spent
guessing what you might like because
wink bass is the wines they send you on
your palate preferences wink will even
introduce you to new rare and custom
wines that are available outside deal
they got a side deal here that not are
not available anywhere else and tell you
the story behind each one this you
always got to look for the side deal
that's a good side deal you know who
cares they go to some local mom-and-pop
a will use this is a rare one
and you give us a little doremi will
feature in maybe you get into the
[ __ ] supermarket someday you know
that's a good deal and right now wink is
offering listeners $20 off your first
order when you go to try wink calm / /
they'll cover the cost of shipping
that's try wink spelled T ry winc comm /
birding at $20 off your first order now
plus complimentary shipping try wink
comm / / they ought to have that for
cigars wink why don't you do that
change it to stink
all right stamps calm everybody last one
I swear to God
stamp save you time and money which you
can use to grow your business for the
hassle of the post office and mail
everything from postcards the envelopes
to packages domestic or international
create your Stamper can try to [ __ ] with
our mail something international what am
i terrorist create your stamp stamps
accountant minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitment stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer stamps
calm makes it easy they'll send you a
digital scale automatically calculates
the exact postage stamps comm will even
help you decide the best class of mail
based on your needs I just don't feel
like my needs are being fulfilled sit
down [ __ ] that's what stamp comp says
and then he satisfies her no need to
lease an expensive postage meter we
already said that I use stamps calm
anytime I'm sending out my posters that
I'm going to sell up to my shows I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out so can you
and right now
you too can enjoy the Stan's dot-com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bur that stamps
comm enter bur alright so the Cavs are
playing tonight oh my god oh my god dude
can you imagine if they [ __ ] win this
one then they going back to Cleveland
this is how quickly it can turn around
this is how fast it can [ __ ] turn
around it would be amazing I haven't
enjoyed a [ __ ] game in a long time
like that I was at a bar of course who's
kidding who I haven't met Billy no fun
I've been Billy less fun today I start
Billy no fun it's just the Cavaliers
have to do what they did the other night
again tonight you know and then again
and then again
but each game I think would be less and
then you know do you realize that the
Cavaliers come back and do this they'd
be the first NBA team to ever do it and
then secondly Steph Curry taking a sh
miming taking a [ __ ] wiping his ass and
like there's that one of the most
classless [ __ ] things you've ever
seen any life
it's like [ __ ] how it guys a dad you
know what I mean I don't understand I
don't I am this just it just makes me
feel old like when he does the no-look
pass and then he [ __ ] he starts
miming like you know he has like
binoculars on as he looks at the crowd
doesn't even look at the end of the it's
like did magic
Johnson ever do that I just I for the
[ __ ] life of me but I will never
understand that that's like that dance
and I told you when I was wet the game
and there was some six year old kid
dancing which should have been adorable
but he had a look on his face like he
wanted to beat the [ __ ] out of me I says
I just don't understand what's going on
with people just a complete lack of
class and humility is you know and this
is coming from a drunk anything I'm
noticing anyways kryptonite everybody
here we go let's do some of these these
these letters here hello bill
hello person I don't know I know you
don't give a [ __ ] but I refuse to stand
by and watch you be an idiot
but the story of Krypton is the planet I
was talking about kryptonite I go isn't
it like [ __ ] natural to his planet
how can Superman be allergic to
kryptonite it's from his planet so this
guy says Krypton the story of Krypton is
the planet exploded from nuclear from a
nuclear chain reaction that's nice and
vague from the family baggy
caused by the planets unstable
radioactive core all right I guess that
was a little more of an explanation
kryptonite being pieces of the
radioactive planet that somehow reach
Earth okay well then shouldn't those
things also affect the humans that go
and get it you know what I mean I don't
understand that
my phone's [ __ ] ringing god damn it
do I got to take this
I'll call them back okay so that's what
it is alright so if the advice somehow
got off earth and I went to Krypton and
the earth exploded they would then be
earth tonight and then Superman could
sit right next to that radioactive rock
I know what this some point you'd be
like bill can you just [ __ ] play
along
and you just play you know why I'm not
playing along because this guy said I
can't watch you be an idiot
watch me be an idiot like kryptonite is
an actual thing this is like you think
I'm an idiot because I can't name all
the Broads on Sex in the City I mean
this is a [ __ ] made-up buddy
alright sorry I don't know the origins
of kryptonite
what what does that gotten you in life
huh
other than a girlfriend with a retainer
in her 30s alright sex everybody I see
that people should be slower to I think
that people should be slower to jump
into bed friendship and respect go a
long way please have Nia in yourself
encourage young people to respect each
other more before sex um listen I I
don't give public service announcements
I mean I just complain about [ __ ] look
if you want to go on get [ __ ] let go
and get laid alright use use it use a
[ __ ] protection but if you actually
are looking for somebody you know to
have more than that then you know I
think uh you know something who I am so
emotionally shut down I can't even speak
on this I don't know I lucked out in to
meet Nia it's just [ __ ] happened all
right but this bouquet I just love that
somebody like this actually wrote in
this is very conservative this is really
interesting I think that people should
be slower to jump into bed friendship
and respect go a long way please have me
and yourself encourage young people's to
respect each other more before sex like
how many listeners do I have my on my
podcast that the Catholic Church is now
trying to slip in public service
announcements well act week well I could
why don't I give everybody southern
accent I'm just gonna have the literally
the Pope in a southern accent say well
after we [ __ ] all those kids no one's
listening to us probiotics everyone hi
Bill I was just listening to some videos
on YouTube on the YouTube channel bill
burr
guys not sure how long ago this one was
from but you are asking for more
information from anyone on how to get
clean probiotics and I just wanted to
say look up kefir ke f ir kefir is not
like a Frei shil slur I believe that's a
racial slur in some country for a group
of people travels so much I forget where
that's fine I'll look that up I hope I'm
not saying that wrong when you have to
[ __ ] apologize hang on a second
kefir racial slur I spelt it like what
they just said oh and my internet
doesn't work why won't you [ __ ] work
now why won't you work yeah at NL oh
that's kaff ir the word kafir is a term
used in South southern of Africa to
refer to a black person alright see that
I knew I watched some sad show and how
people treat each other so I must be
saying that wrong I'm gonna say kefir
like Southerland kefir you can buy the
grains and you just add them to your
organic milk milk and then two days
later approximately you have kefir
yogurt much better than the store-bought
ones because they get pasteurized and
hence you lose a lot of the bacteria
okay Cheers [ __ ] have a good one all
right but then what about the milk what
do I get the milk I get the milk from an
organic cow and why don't I just lay off
the booze I just do that would that be
easier um all right lady needing advice
don't want to go to male friend's
wedding oh this is great I can give you
advice on this my girlfriend's ex was
gross
lady needing advice don't want to go to
male friend's wedding
my girlfriend's ex was gross I don't get
okay hi bill I'm a 23 year old guy what
the [ __ ] is this I think the lady
needing advice somehow got cut off so
this is a different one
my girlfriend's ex was gross where's the
lady needing advice don't want to go to
male friend's wedding I will get to the
bottom of that by Thursday
all right hi Bill I'm a 23 year old guy
and I recently moved in with my 23 year
old girlfriend everything was going
awesome until one drunken night she
starts to tell me what her ex-boyfriend
was like okay she explains that when she
was 20 she dated this guy who will call
Joe who was 11 years older than her
which already [ __ ] with my head so
being insecure the next day I decided to
look him up online and he's disgusting
he's fat with an unkempt beard and
really short in a pudgy face I just
can't wrap my head around the fact that
my girl being so hot young bang the slob
of a man picturing the two of the two
together doing what we do now is really
messed up messing me up to the point we
stopped having sex a week ago I just
can't get it out of my head I mean at
one point that disgusting mess really
turned her on gross am I just being an
[ __ ] do I break up with her honestly
I just don't look at her the same way
anymore I can handle her vast sexual
history before me but not with that mess
it's really screwing me thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself all right here's one of
these things that if you were a woman
they would be like well you have to
honor that you have to know no means no
and if you don't like this then you
should honor that that's what you're
feeling and your partner if they really
love you should understand this and wait
until you're able to perform again but
that's not how it works with guys you
would be judged for being so [ __ ]
superficial and blah blah blah blah
[ __ ] superficial writing the amount
of young [ __ ] that I saw with these
old [ __ ] guys at that f1 race you
know I don't know what you do to be
honest with you but I mean this is what
I would do in the future I wouldn't
Google people she used to [ __ ] it's
probably a bad thing but I'm thinking
you're only 23 years old how did you
know so she used to [ __ ] this troll
probably under a bridge yeah that's kind
of gross
probably ate some [ __ ] one of those
short but fat dicks you know peeking out
of his pubes oh that's so disgusting I
would talk to her about it I would just
say listen you know I was insecure that
you that you were with an older man and
was you know not confident about what I
was doing with you in bed and my
curiosity got the best of me and I
googled that guy dude for all you know
you got the wrong guy by the way it
might be someone with the same name who
knows you know I don't know but it's I
don't know in a week's time you can't
get past that I mean she's probably
looking at you like you're a champion if
that guy was a 34 year old fat
disgusting [ __ ] you're 23 imagining
in shape right um I don't know I don't
think it's weird that you looked at the
guy and then all of a sudden his picture
and [ __ ] your girlfriend that's
disgusting I don't think that's weird at
all
women would say it is because they
always defend each other for some reason
yet they [ __ ] go at each other like
alley cats when we're not around I don't
know there's I get it's like some female
like Union you know they act like Union
and in men are not unionized which is
every man from [ __ ] self
um although I am sticking up for you so
who knows um yeah I would know I think I
talked to her about it just say you know
do you think this makes me superficial
she's gonna be like yes I can't believe
you judge me like that I just I don't
judge people on looks
I know you judge them on their wallets
um if he has a nice personality in a
private jet you know I don't mind a
little extra weight yeah what was going
on with that guy
maybe that fat troll is taken out to a
nice restaurant every night so he could
keep her and that's how he got fat I
don't know you have a giant head too
those big [ __ ] butcher Blockheads
all right jealousy issues jealousy
issues dear Billy rosy cheeks first up
I'm a huge fan keep up all the great
work anyway me and my girlfriend of four
years just moved to France she is French
and all her family is here we lived in
Australia and planned to go back to
Australia in 11 months sorry I had to
get that Jana our relationship is very
serious
we never laugh no I'm kidding I love
this girl's so much and plan on popping
the question soon we were at a local bar
last night
I'm not lingual enough to talk well at a
bar yet so when we go out it's hard to
follow what's being said but I still
have a pretty good time after I had a
few drinks with her and her friends this
guy my girlfriend works with sits with
us while it's just me and her
about 3:00 a.m. and I immediately felt
bad I'd never met this dude but when he
sat down my girlfriend didn't look at me
for 10 minutes and was 100% focusing
focused on him leaning in laughing
etcetera while I sat on my phone or
looking up at the sports yeah dude
that's not good that's not good
repeat that is not good I couldn't
understand what they were talking about
and there wasn't a way I could be a part
of it I didn't like the way this guy was
looking at me as well twice during the
time after 10 minutes she struggle II
puts her hand on my knee and after five
more minutes I tell her we should leave
I say goodbye to her friends and walk
outside I smoke a cigarette and wait a
bit longer go back inside and she's
still at the bar with this guy
paying her bill same ambience as before
when we leave to walk home I mean I'm
immediately cold with her you should
have been she [ __ ] embarrassed you
you absolutely should have been Yuji why
you wouldn't do that to her would you I
was pretty drunk so I expressed my
dislike for this situation in an overly
angry in an impatient manner yeah you
should have waited to you so this one of
these things what you were right and
then you were drunk and then you became
wrong by the way you said it 20 minutes
into a 30-minute walk home she was
tearing up pretty bad and told me she
was talking about me another harmless
[ __ ] bull [ __ ] [ __ ] she was talking
about her dog and her dog was sitting
next to it at some point she be like
look at his face she would have done
that she's full of [ __ ] this is my gut
anyways well the feelings stayed between
us when we woke up this morning I don't
get to socialize much here and I really
like this bar where everybody goes to
but this felt particularly bad my
girlfriend acts more natural in this
country so this is awesome for her to be
with her fellow countrymen but we've
never in four years had a conflict where
jealousy is an issue have you ever had
an issue where your girl's talking to a
dude and it crosses a line absolutely
absolutely and I was drunk and I said
something yeah and that didn't end well
can I deal with this without affecting
the relationship or how my girl act
socially deep down she's an absolute
sweetheart and really sensitive so it's
a bit delicate also there's a part of me
that says maybe it's all in my head
anyways hope you can help bill any
advice would be great love to the burr
family and go [ __ ] yourself all right
well there's so many factors yeah you
could be jealous but you know if it was
actually ten minutes and she didn't look
at you and then I said I'll meet you
outside and she said she's still in
there talking to him about what a
[ __ ] great guy you are you at some
point to you your gut doesn't lie unless
your heads [ __ ] up all right if it's
coming from your gut if it's not coming
from between your ears and it's all this
fearful thoughts that she had
and you need to quiet that down but if
it's coming from your gut you judge guts
just saying this just isn't [ __ ]
right and who's kidding who the French
have different ideas about that type of
[ __ ] where you know I'm not saying
everybody over there but they they're
the whole [ __ ] having a mich mistress
you know he's not looked down upon it
seems sort of accepted yes the
resentment builds I don't [ __ ] know
but I don't that whole situation has
been I actually think her reaching over
and patting you on the [ __ ] leg to
keep to keep you at bay there I even
think that that that makes it that made
it even worse now having said all that
you should have waited till the next
morning or at least when you walk back
then I just say listen I'm a little
drunk right now
so I don't want to have a big
conversation but I would like to talk to
you about what just went down with that
guy like that ever works with a woman
knowing about you know um I don't know
what the deal who knows who knows what
the [ __ ] that was I would be like
alright so is she only the way she is
because she's in my country and she
doesn't know anybody but this is how she
this is how she really is is this just a
cultural thing did she used to [ __ ] this
guy and she's psyched to see him and
this is going to be her little [ __ ]
fling on the side when we get married I
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] to think but
I would try to regroup and just be like
you know I find it hard to believe that
if I was at a bar and I started speaking
a language with another woman that you
didn't know and I didn't even look at
you for 10 minutes and then gave you a
pandering pat on the [ __ ] leg and
then tried and then I went outside for a
smoke and I came back in he was still in
there talking this person this woman if
I was talking I'm saying if
was talking to this woman that I was
somehow be able to convince you that I
was talking about you the whole time I
don't know what to tell you sir other
than to practice up on your French
practice up on your French and do it
without her knowing
get that rosetta stone should get your
French game in order and learn all their
menage a 12 [ __ ] what's what's ass
over there
gross G ro s something like that you got
to know what the [ __ ] he's saying to
your girlfriend so I don't know I don't
want to tell you do my gut says that
that was [ __ ] up I could just tell you
that I'm not trying to drive you away
from this woman but that's that seem
[ __ ] up if that was coming from you
gut sir god damn it I would go with it
all right that's it that's the podcast
if you enjoy this podcast and you'd like
to donate without a caution you a dime
just go to billboard.com click on the
podcast page and there's an amazon link
there anytime you want to buy something
off of Amazon just go to my webpage
click on the link I get credit for
driving traffic to the website doesn't
cost you any more money whatever you
were going to buy they kicked me a
little [ __ ] cash eesh or whatever
[ __ ] tidbits whatever they call those
those PayPal money coin things breaks it
I don't know it's called um that's it
that's what you can do and if you don't
want to do that I completely understand
I don't give a [ __ ] if you keep
listening you cheap [ __ ] alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourself I'll check in on you
on Thursday let's go Cavs
congratulations penguins my condolences
to Nashville fans thank you to everybody
at the Formula One race and I can't wait
to watch the next race I don't even know
where the hell is that
but I will be watching I actually
finally watched the Italian gram mole
OGP by the way trying to take those
[ __ ] races is so difficult every time
I go to click it's the [ __ ] moto 3
moto 2 it's the [ __ ] time trial I
always got to click every single [ __ ]
one of them before I finally get to the
race I got to see the Italian when these
[ __ ] were going like 220 miles
an hour on motorcycles I finally figured
out the
I'm gonna think every 50 miles an hour
is 80 kilometers so you just keep adding
80 every 50 so 50 100 miles an hour 150
200 miles an hour is 81 60 to 40
what the [ __ ] would that be 320 roughly
all right there you go there's a little
metric system for you go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll see you on Thursday
you